on
le destin tragique de lady diana le
conte de fées a tourné au drame cette
nuit à paris à 36 ans lady diana trouvé
la mort dans un accident de voiture en
compagnie de son nouvel ami le
milliardaire égyptien
dodi al fayed leur voiture poursuivie
par des paparazzi à moto roulait à très
grande vitesse lorsque le conducteur en
a perdu le contrôle
récit pascal golomer patrick voit une
carcasse littéralement broyé l'état de
la voiture témoigne de la violence
extrême du choc la puissante mercedes
était lancé à pleine vitesse dans le
tunnel de l'alma en plein paris vers
zéro heure trente sans doute plus de 150
km pour une raison encore inconnue
elle est venue heurter le mur fut l'un
des piliers du tunnel à son bord quatre
personnes
lady diana son ami dodi al fayed un
garde du corps et le chauffeur il venait
de quitter l'hôtel ritz place vendôme
pour fausser compagnie aux paparazzi qui
les suivaient à moto le chauffeur aurait
alors décidé de rouler très vite trop
vite
lorsque la police et les secours
arrivent sur place
dodi al fayed et le chauffeur sont déjà
décédés la princesse de galles
elle peut être désincarcéré l'opération
prend plus d'une heure avant le
transfert vers l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière
pendant ce temps l'enquète débute cette
photographe sont rapidement emmené dans
les locaux de la brigade criminelle
les motos sont saisis comme pièces à
conviction peu avant 6 heures à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
les journalistes sont conviés à une
conférence de presse improvisée une
thoracotomie d'urgence a mis en évidence
une plaie importante de la veine
pulmonaire gauche malgré la fermeture de
cette plaie et un massage cardiaque
externe puis interne de 12 heures aucune
efficacité circulatoire n'a pu être
rétablie et le décès a été constaté à 4
heures du matin j'adresse les
condoléances de la france à la famille
royale
aux familles des victimes et au peuple
britannique tout entier lady diana était
une personne très aimé en france une
femme moderne courageuse sensible à la
détresse humaine sa disparition sera
ressentie douloureusement dans notre
pays
quai des orfèvres les sept photographes
sont alors toujours interrogé par les
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
le jour se lève les premiers parisien se
présente sous le tunnel de l'alma ou
rendre un dernier hommage à lady diana
princesse de galles
très grièvement blessée la princesse
diana donc été transporté au service de
réanimation de l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière où le décès a été constaté à
4 heures du matin l'ambiance sur place
avec ce reportage de valérie fourni et
michel levasseur le premier ministre
lionel jospin et bernadette chirac sont
arrivés à hanover dans deux voitures
séparées précédé de peu par
l'ambassadeur de grande bretagne en
france depuis très tôt ce matin une
foule d'anonymes s'est pressée devant
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière où
lady diana est décédée cette nuit à 4
heures du matin pour moi elle était
adorable
m
ce
c'est d'entendre way
ça les mecs
alors tu vis
nous sommes tous faits
c'est beaucoup de bien on lui a toujours
fait du mal et les gens qui leur fait du
match c'est vraiment répugnant
voilà et ça vraiment ça nous touche
vraiment à coeur une colère à mots
couverts contre la presse en particulier
ceux qui violent la vie privée des stars
pour de fortes sommes
une colère que certains n'arrivait pas à
contenir même bouleversé au delà de tout
ce qu'elle a pu faire c'est fallait pas
la traque et dans sa vie privée c'est
leur gardien de coeur elle est toujours
à la poursuite d'un l'espèce de d'argent
qui est de l'argent ce vendredi c'est le
capitalisme à la sauvage la mort n'est
ce pas de cette fois ci generis
quand même et puis table n'est ce pas
aux médias tout ce que je voyais des
journaux tout ce que je voyais orange
j'aime ou tout autre collection même les
dernières qui vient de sortir tout parce
que même la presse à scandale quand même
vous en voulez aux photographes qui les
suivaient janvier j'en vois énormément à
la presse qu'il ait suivi une presse
encore très présents ce matin devant
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière où les
badauds continue d'affirmer dans le
silence et le recueillement
d'autres m'ont tout de suite en direct
de l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
benoît duquesne benoît le prince charles
est attendu dans l'après midi
oui tout à fait le prince charles était
confirmée un peu plus tard dans la
matinée depuis londres le prince charles
doit se rendre ici
cet après midi on sait que les
cérémonies ici seront brèves puisque
après qu'il se soit recueilli sur la
dépouille de son ex-femme et bien le
corps de lady diana doit être rapatrié
sur londres où là les cérémonies
officielles en angleterre auront lieu
tout cela doit se faire relativement
rapidement dans l'après midi on ne sait
pas encore si d'autres personnalités que
celles qui sont déjà venus ce matin
doivent se rendre encore ici cet après
midi mais il y à issy comme vous le
voyez pas mal de badauds de gens qui
sont là pour les uns pour témoigner de
leur affection pour la princesse et pour
d'autres pour voir un petit peu comment
les choses évoluent voici jacques chirac
a fait part de sa vive émotion évoquant
la mémoire de lady diana
une jeune femme de notre temps
chaleureuse pleine de vie et de
générosité la plupart des grands de ce
monde ont fait part de leur tristesse et
de leur consternation
de nombreux curieux se sont rendus ce
matin sur les lieux de l'accident dans
le tunnel du pont de l'alma nous
retrouvons sur place ont directement et
pierre farkas
oui nous assistons depuis ce matin des
scènes de recueillement des scènes
recueillement populaire anonyme
vous voyez juste derrière moi sur le
point il ya un bouquet de roses il n'y
en aura qu'un parce que maintenant des
policiers interdisent à la fois l'accès
du tunnel et les alentours
depuis ce matin vous allez voir sur ces
images tournées par jacques gregor
depuis ce matin 9 heures ce sont des
français des badauds des passants
des touristes étrangers qui sont venus
des britanniques chacun portait une
fleur sous ce treizième coteaux du
tunnel du pont de l'alma
écoutez lente et moyens juridiques elle
est très triste on pense que diana était
une bassesse gentil qu'elle l'aimé
beaucoup et beaucoup de gens sont
tristes objets que j'ai appris la
nouvelle ce matin
allant chercher mon pain j'ai tout de
suite eu une pensée pour les deux trains
sont bien évidemment bon jeu
je ne vais pas tarder à aller à la messe
et je vais les porter dans ma prière je
crois que c'est la seule chose
personnellement que je puisse faire
il ya eu des fleurs ce matin beaucoup de
fleurs des larmes des femmes assez
triste et puis surtout un début de
polémique parce que beaucoup des gens
qui étaient là ne voulait pas témoigner
parce qu'ils étaient émus mais d'autres
ne voulaient pas s'adresser à la presse
comme ce touriste anglais qui refuse de
parler à la presse qui la rend
responsable or dans le courant de la
matinée nous avons rencontré d'autres
témoins qui le disaient que finalement
il avait vu une voiture vous connaissez
la fragilité de ces témoignages dans ces
instants-là vu une voiture qui ne s'est
pas accompagnée de motards en tout cas
il se passe ici le plus beau témoignage
que nous ayons recueillie est celui
d'une femme israélienne qui faisait
qu'il n'y a pas de façon intelligente de
mourir mais que celle ci était
particulièrement stupide si marie pierre
farkas pour toutes ces précisions pour
le premier ministre britannique lady
d'aiete la princesse du peuple à 20 en
juillet 80 elle avait épousé charles
l'héritier du trône britannique
en compagnie de patrice romedenne récit
d'un conte de fées qui a tourné à la
tragédie
la majesté de l'endroit est à la mesure
de l'événement
le 29 juillet 1981 à la cathédrale saint
paul de londres le prince charles
épouser une jeune fille issue de la
fleur de l'aristocratie britten en
liesse les sujets de sa majesté fait
l'élu adopté dès l'annoncé des
fiançailles les pommettes rosies par
l'amour et la gaucherie la désormais
princesse 19 ans s'affiche au bras de
charles 32 ans
ils s'aiment et ils le disent vous vous
aimez bien sûr de l' union naîtront deux
enfants et l'ennui ce préambule à
l'explosion du couple harry et william
aujourd'hui 13 et 15 ans seule la
progéniture rapproche les parents il
aime la solitude le polo la philosophie
hindoue et l architecture
il apprécie berlioz elle se déhanche sur
d'ailleurs ce trade secours les
discothèques et les balles chacun vie
ses passions en solitaire et la lune de
miel la sombre dans le caniveau
il renoue avec camilla une amie
d'enfance elle s'amourache de jane sa
capitaine de cavalerie
pire aux yeux de buckingham c'est
qu'elle parle avec le capitaine êtes
vous allé au delà de l'amitié
je les fais avec vous été infidèle et ça
tourne
est-ce que je l'adorais j'étais
amoureuse de lui mais à quoi bon cachet
ou tenté de le faire des couvertures par
centaines d articles par milliers
pendant 17 ans la princesse aura vécu
avec dans son sillage un bataillon de
paparazzi soirées mondaines officiel ou
comme ici escapade privé dans un club de
gym
rien n'échappe à l'objectif des amateurs
de scoop dont l'assistance n'a d'égal
que la popularité de leur proie
le fil des révélations mais le couperet
du divorce cordone une reine ulcéré par
les déclarations de la princesse diana
perd son titre d'altesse mais conserve
celui de princesse de galles
elle empoche 23 millions de dollars et
munis de tels atouts entame une carrière
d'ambassadrice des grandes causes
symbolique la rencontre avec mère teresa
des enfants aux malades du sida en
passant par les victimes des mines
antipersonnel elle s'enquiert du ca
l'état de la planète
la seconde existence d'une femme dans la
force de l'âge dont la presse se fait
l'écho sans pour autant abandonner la
manne de la vie privée car en parallèle
la princesse conquiert un milliardaire
et playboy égyptien l'idylle nourrira le
roman-photo de l'été c'est à ses côtés
qu'elle est décédée cette nuit faisant
du coeur des britanniques son tombeau
dans un communiqué la reine elizabeth et
le prince charles se sont déclarés
anéantis par cette disparition tony
blair se dit totalement effondré pour le
premier ministre britannique
la grande bretagne est une nation
éplorée du fait d'une mort profondément
douloureuse à londres profond ce2
etienne leenhardt
devant les grilles de buckingham palace
tôt ce matin le silence pour ce que tout
un peuple ressent comme une tragique
diana princesse de galles est morte dans
la nuit et leur peine est immense
nous sommes rentrer à la maison nous
avons entendu la nouvelle nous avons
suivi la télévision toute la nuit je
suis profondément choquée elle a su
donner du courage aux malades
elle était pleine de compassion la
presse l'a fait ils l'ont vraiment
fabriquer et maintenant ils l'ont tué
j'espère qu'ils en ont conscience la
même émotion devant les grilles de
kensington palace la résidence de diana
depuis son divorce des fleurs par
dizaines des messages
et à l'heure des prières là encore une
immense émotion
nous sommes tous extrêmement choquée et
horrifiée
elle était merveilleuse ne savait faire
que le bien le choc et l'horreur absolue
avant de se rendre à l'office en
compagnie de sa femme et de ses enfants
tony blair le premier ministre
visiblement ému à évoquer sa mémoire est
un être merveilleux rempli de chaleur
humaine sa vie avaient été marquées par
plusieurs drames mais combien de gens
at-elle su aider ici en grande-bretagne
est partout à travers le monde depuis 4
heures ce matin les programmes de toutes
les chaînes de télévision ont été
interrompues inlassablement les
chroniqueurs de la famille royale
évoquent sa mémoire sur le toit des
magasins harrods propriété du père de
dodi al fayed le drapeau britannique est
en baisse on trouve tout de suite en
direct du palais de buckingham étienne
nollet nantes estienne le prince charles
était cette nuit au château de balmoral
en écosse et c'est apparemment lui est
lui-même qui a annoncé à ses deux
enfants la mort de leur mère oui c'est
effectivement ce que rapportent les
agences de presse officielles
britannique le prince charles et appris
la nouvelle pendant la nuit
comme tout le monde ici en grande
bretagne et aux 18 au début ce journal
je crois qu'il ya énormément d'émotion à
la mesure de la popularité qui était
celle de
de la princesse de galles ici en grande
bretagne même si elle avait été critiqué
en certaines circonstances
nous sommes à buckingham palace où la
traditionnelle relève de la garde n'a
pas été annulé pour la circonstance il
ya donc un mélange curieux de d'émotion
et en même temps de tradition il y avait
énormément de touristes vous l'imaginez
mais beaucoup de gens qui sont venus
également pour assister
traditionnellement à la relève de la
garde le prince charles
il se rendra on l'a dit tout à l'heure à
à paris en compagnie des deux soeurs de
la princesse de galles pour se
recueillir sur la dépouille de son ex
femme et pour ramener la dépouille de la
princesse de galles en grande bretagne
on ne sait pas encore quelle apparence
seront les cérémonies officielles car
vous savez depuis un an depuis qu'elle a
divorcé
la princesse de galles ne fait plus
officiellement partie de la famille
royale tout à l'heure à l'occasion de la
spéciale qui suivra ce journal qui sera
présentée par daniel bilalian
cette romance avec le milliardaire
égyptien dodi al fayed le fils d'un des
hommes les plus controversées de grande
bretagne
cette île en inde et provoqué outre
manche un certain nombre de critiques
pour ne pas dire plus elle avait débuté
comme un roman feuilleton elle s'est
donc achevée dramatiquement cette nuit à
paris sous la traque des paparazzi en
fait depuis ses fiançailles avec charles
à l'âge de 19 ans cette jeune femme
avait vécu constamment sous les
objectifs des caméras
etienne leenhardt à la une des éditions
spéciales de la matinée imprimé à la
hâte le dernier acte de ce qu'un
éditorialiste qualifie de tragédie
grecque
n'hésitant pas à mettre directement en
cause les paparazzis qu'elle sorte de
son club de gymnastique de chez elles ou
de nulle part il y avait toujours un
micro pour obtenir une confidence un
appareil pour figer un sourire une larme
ou un geste d'énervement la romance de
diana avec charge leur divorce leur
idylle respectives mobiliser plus la
presse britannique que tout autre
événement une publicité qu'elle jugeait
forcément excessive
au cours d'une journée normale je serai
poursuivi par quatre voitures de presse
au cours d'une journée normale jeu
reviendra ma voiture et je retrouverai
si paparazzi pour le piéger ils ont
décidé qu'après 15 16 ans je suis
toujours un produit qui vendit ce papier
connue pour être la personne la plus
photographiée au monde en toutes
circonstances diana aura mis ces
dernières années sa médiatisation au
service des grandes causes
la médecine l'humanitaire et des
déplacements fréquents aux endroits les
plus misérables du monde où la présence
des photographes qu'elle entraîner
derrière elle était cette fois
nécessaire c'est très souvent par les
médias que la princesse communiquer avec
le public
elle avait une place dans le coeur du
public et je ne pense pas qu'on verra
quelqu'un d'autre prendre cette place
suivi pas à pas ces dernières semaines
jusque sur le yacht de son ami dodi al
fayed
dyan havre a dénoncé jusqu'au bout les
photographes qui la traquent et ceux là
mêmes qui depuis quinze ans ont aussi
contribué à bâtir son immense popularité
je vous propose maintenant d'entendre le
témoignage du frère de lady d'ailleurs
charles spencer
il évoque la responsabilité des
paparazzi dans ce drame n'est pas le
temps des accusations mais celui de la
tristesse je dirais cependant que j'ai
toujours pensé que la presse finirait
par la tuer mais je ne pensais pas
qu'ils auraient une responsabilité aussi
direct dans sa mort il semble apparaître
que tous les patrons presse toutes les
publications qui ont payé pour
encourager le travail d'intrusion de
photographes qui ne cherchait que de
l'argent dans la vie privée de diana ont
aujourd'hui du sang sur leurs marques
le milliardaire égyptien
dodi al fayed a donc je vous rappelle
trouvé la mort lui aussi dans cet
accident
son père c'est bien évidemment rendu dès
qu'il a eu connaissance du drame à paris
voyez sortir cachés par des gardes du
clan de l'hôtel du ritz à paris
les circonstances de cet accident vont
faire l'objet d'une enquête
particulièrement minutieuse enquête
confiée à la brigade criminelle une
procédure tout à fait exceptionnel
plusieurs photographes de presse sont
entendus depuis cette nuit au quai des
orfèvres où nous trouvons tout de suite
en direct christophe tortora christophe
ces photographes serait en garde à vue
oui tout à fait il ya donc sept
photographes qui sont en temps d'initier
à la brigade criminelle c'est une
procédure exceptionnelle en raison de la
personnalité bien sûr des victimes les
sept hommes suivaient à moto la voiture
de lady di et du prince d'audi ils sont
donc entendus ici ils veulent témoigner
ils doivent témoigner des circonstances
exactes de l'accident sur ces sept
hommes six photographes sont de
nationalité française
le septième et les nationalité
macédonienne ils les motos de ses
photographes les appareils photos ont
été saisies par les inspecteurs de la
police judiciaire pour tenter de
comprendre les circonstances exactes de
cet accident
le soft aura une question que risque
précisément sur le plan pénal ces
photographes
en fait tout dépend de la part de
responsabilité qui incombe à ces
photographes si le procureur estime
qu'ils sont totalement ou en partie
responsable de l'accident
il pourrait être mise en examen pour
homicide involontaire mais selon
certains témoins les photographes et les
motos se trouve à quelques centaines de
mètres derrière la voiture derrière la
mercedes de la princesse et du prince
d'audi
quoi qu'il en soit les photographes
certains photographes pourrait être mise
en examen pour non-assistance à personne
en danger puisque certains d'entre eux
on continue à prendre des photos après
l'accident plutôt que de venir en aide
aux personnes qui étaient blessés ou
tués lors de cet accident et certains
d'entre eux pourraient être également
poursuivi pour délit de fuite puisqu'ils
ont tenté d'échapper au contrôle de
police après l'accident
le procureur doit qualifier les faits
maintenant et un juge d'instruction
pourrait être
dès cet après midi ainsi christophe
comptera dans sa toute dernière
interview lady diana avait dénoncé la
férocité d'une presse gay poncet moindre
faux pas la polémique on a vu s'annonce
particulièrement rude sur les
circonstances exactes de ce drame et sur
les responsabilités respectives des
paparazzi à moto et du chauffeur de la
mercedes tout de suite l'analyse de
benoît duquesne en direct ouais c'est
vrai qu'il faut d'abord être très très
prudent et attendre bien sûr les
recettes à cette enquête avant de se
prononcer sur une application directe
des paparazzi dans cet accident puisque
les photographes vous le savez s'en
défendent en disant qu'il ne faisait que
suivre quelqu'un qui plus que personne
au monde avait l'habitude de ce genre
d'activité puisque c'était la femme la
plus photographiée du monde et bien sûr
cette affaire va reposer la question des
délicats rapports entre les stars et la
presse des rapports qui sont bien sûr
inévitable il n'y a pas de starisation
sans médiatisation des rapports qui sont
parfois ambigu on sait des vedettes qui
monnayait arranger deal et les
indiscrétions pouvaient révéler la
presse à leur égard est en tout cas des
rapports qui sont difficiles à définir
on sait qu il n'y a pas de stars sans
qu'il y est il n'y a pas de stars sans
qu'il y ait une part de sa vie privée
qu'ils soient révélés avant public
le tout est de savoir quelle est
l'importance de cette part de la vie
privée qui doit être révélé
et c'est là toute la limite et c'est là
que depuis quelques années on assiste à
une sorte de dérive de cette presse à
scandale de cette presse people comme on
dit qui se montre de plus en plus
agressive au nom du droit d'informer
alors il faut dire que la demande est
forte elle aussi puisque pour ne citer
qu'un chiffre les sept principales
publications hebdomadaires qui sont
spécialisés dans ce genre de d'actualité
sur la place de paris est bien
représente plus de 3 millions d'abonnés
fin de lecteurs de d'acheteurs ce qui
veut dire 20 millions de personnes qui
lisent ces journaux l'as et c'est vrai
que beaucoup de gens ici qui faisait le
procès des paparazzi ce matin
reconnaissait que par ailleurs ils
étaient les premiers à se jeter sur les
kiosques pour voir les photos qui
avaient été prises à l'occasion de ces
courses poursuites merci lionel jospin
qui est à la rochelle pour participer à
l'université d'été du ps est venu tôt ce
matin s'incliner devant la dépouille de
la princesse diana
de retour à la rochelle le premier
ministre a adressé ses condoléances aux
enfants de l'île
il est bien ce que j'ai ressenti en
apprenant la mort de lady diana
c'est qu'il était profondément triste
que cette belle jeune femme aimée par
les gens mais dont tous les faits était
scruté les faits et les gestes a terminé
sa vie tragiquement en france à paris et
comme je sais que les français ont
toujours été séduit par son charme par
son naturel par son humanité
j'ai eu envie de faire un geste en
direction aussi de nos amis en grande
bretagne naturellement au nom du
gouvernement j'adresse mes condoléances
à la famille royale aux autorités
britanniques et surtout aux enfants et
aux proches de lady diana déclaration
donc fait ce matin la rochelle où lionel
jospin participe à l'université d'été du
ps
l'occasion d'un discours très politique
tout à l'heure en fin de matinée sur
place nous retrouvons un guilaine chenu
hervé pozzo la tenue est plus sombre et
plus formelle après un aller retour à
paris pour s'incliner devant la
dépouille de la princesse diana
mais j'espère retrouve les siens c'est
ici que traditionnellement les
socialistes font leur rentrée politique
l'année dernière il accueille est un
premier secrétaire aujourd'hui c'est un
premier ministre qu'ils applaudissent
l'occasion après trois mois de pouvoir
dresser un bilan
alors c'est un grand show relève déjà
des écarts entre promesses de campagne
action gouvernementale lionel jospin
défend un réalisme de gauche exemple
l'immigration et le choix de ne pas
abroger les lois pasqua debré en réalité
sur le fond je suis resté constant dans
mon approche et mes positions
quant au gouvernement il a bien
l'intention de respecter ses engagements
de campagne
vous avez d'ailleurs pu le vérifier dès
les premières semaines par les
régularisations qu'autorise la
circulaire du ministre de l'intérieur
hélas les faits valent le poids des baux
aïe une mise au point destinée à tous
ceux qui à gauche serait tenté
d'instruire des procès au gouvernement
pour mener le jeu ce pas ce qui est en
jeu c'est bien le lien de confiance
qu'ils souhaitent nouer avec les
français en algérie le responsable du
gia pour l'ouest du pays auraient été
abattus par les forces de sécurité à
noter à noter également et surtout une
prise de position importante du chef du
front islamique du salut
abassi madani qui dans une lettre
adressée au secrétaire général de l'onu
se déclare prêt à lancer immédiatement
un appel à l'arrêt des violences en
algérie
abassi madani a été libéré le 15 juillet
dernier après six ans prison ou encore
en surveillance en résidence surveillée
le chef du fils dissous en temps je cite
faciliter l'ouverture d'un dialogue
sérieux qui aboutira à une fin heureuse
de la crise dans l'actualité de ce
dimanche également la cinquième soirée
du championnat de france de football
quatre jours après sa retentissante
victoire en coupe d'europe le psg a
poursuivi sur sa lancée en surclassant
hier soir rennes 4 à 1 les parisiens
confortent ainsi leur place de dauphin
florent gautreau séquence émotion au
parc leonardo l'un des héros de mercredi
ses adieux des larmes plein les yeux
il part jouer au milan ac mais même sans
lui paris ses marques et 33e minutes une
fusée signé and beauty d'école du parc
atterrissage réussi dans la lucarne du
but rennais et pour la deuxième fois en
une semaine le public parisien va être
gâté et comblé marco simone et marquent
deux buts en cinq minutes rennes réduira
le score sur penalty mais le psg termine
son feu d'artifice comme il l'avait
commencé une fusée allumé par paul le
guen 5-0 mercredi 4-1 samedi psg revit
l'entraîneur bordelais guy stéphan fait
la moue son équipe est menée 2 1 par
auxerre à la mi temps mais à la 51e
minute qui qui nous semble pas s'envole
et marque le plus beau but de la journée
et bordeaux bat même l'emporter 3-2
grâce à vilvorde qui marque le but
vainqueur à neuf minutes de la fin
bordeaux a eu chaud mais bordeaux a
gagné 24 buts inscrits et trois
victoires à l'extérieur
bastia 3e l'a emporté à lyon et cannes à
gagner à châteauroux son premier match
de la saison
et enfin en championnat du monde de
cyclisme sur piste qui se déroule
actuellement en australie une sixième
médaille d'or pour les tricolores
tout à l'heure florian rousseau en effet
conservé son titre de champion du monde
de vitesse se payant le luxe de battre
le champion olympique l'allemand
fidelaire par deux manches à zéro dans
quelques minutes après la météo une page
de publicité édition spéciale sur la
disparition de lady diana en compagnie
de nos envoyés spéciaux et de nos
invités édition présentée par daniel
bilalian
je vous retrouve ce soir à 20h très très
bonne après midi
nous